hey there guys so I've got something a
little bit different for you guys today
I've got a full conversation with none
other than Ben Patrick knees over toes
guy if you've been living under a
fitness Rock I have no idea what a
fitness Rock would be and you don't know
who Ben Patrick is he's essentially the
guy who's been championing bringing
these over toes in squats and other
movements demonstrating how actually
placing a little bit of pressure on the
knee joint isn't going to instantly blow
out your knees in fact it's what builds
the resilience to ensure that they don't
blow out and he has helped thousands of
people to recover from knee injuries
he's helped athletes train to do
incredible things he himself bounced
back from multiple knee injuries to
being able to dunk and do incredible
things like leaping off a ladder into a
city Squat and what have you but his
ideas go far beyond just strengthening
the knees they also apply to
strengthening the shoulders the back
essentially created a system the atg
system that can be applied to any aspect
of your performance any joint to not
only build resilience and prevent injury
to help encourage recovery but also to
massively improve performance to make
you more explosive elastic stronger and
yeah it just has a lot of really
insightful ideas when it comes to
exercise selection and ways to train and
in this conversation he shared tons of
that with me and was really open and
generous with his time and knowledge not
only did he outline basically how you
can approach this kind of training for
any part of your body using a
progression system to make sure you ease
gently into it we also discussed how he
would apply that to other aspects of his
training he talked about his own
personal goals and I think it might
surprise some of you actually to learn
what he's training for next it certainly
did me so yeah it's definitely worth the
watch I'll put timestamps in the
description so you can jump around to
the bits that interest you and I'll
leave links in the description as well
to all of his stuff if you want to check
that out thanks again Tunisia Victorious
guy for appearing this video and I hope
you find it really enlightening as I did
it doesn't really tie into the theme of
the video but I did want to ask you
about sort of managing your your work
life balance and and training because
that's that's the other thing you've got
to train do your own training on top of
the filming on top of the being the dad
and
I don't know about you personally but
for me like getting
um back like when I get into the office
there's only so much I have to do that's
also actually when I train that and at
night time but even then you're like do
I edit this video a bit more do I do my
workout like and if you don't do the
workout that's kind of what the video is
about so you can't just
have you found it a challenge since
you've got yeah so I I always do my
workout first so every video you ever
see me do I already did my workout so
yeah so it forces me to get it done and
also if I'm gonna be demonstrating
something I don't want to only be able
to do that if I'm perfectly fresh on the
first set like
I want to be able to do it even when I'm
tired after a workout yeah but if I
didn't if I didn't do the workout first
yeah I would just work forget about my
own workout and it would mess the whole
thing up so yeah no that's it because
it's so easy to sort of push that to
later and then later doesn't come
otherwise and that's the interesting
point you said about trying to do it
when you already a bit fatigued because
that's that's something I've like
found to be challenging is especially
because my videos are all on different
like I mean yours are as well like on
such different topics so one day I'll be
doing like almost entirely push-ups or
I'll be doing it almost entirely some
kind of squat and like that's not a
normal workout and actually gets quite
time with the camera angles and
everything and you've you say if you've
just done a workout as well how about
how about another chemistry and across
yeah but
That's My Philosophy is like I like to
um think of things with a long-term view
so my view is all right if I'm shooting
a Nordic hamstring girl video
I'm gonna do my workout
then I'm gonna start shooting the video
and if I mess up my line yeah great rest
repeat more gains in the long run that's
how I do it so so it's almost like the
filming
actually makes me work out uh the
filming forces me to work out even
harder yeah yeah so yeah some days it's
tougher than others when you're doing
something like where you know where you
have extreme soreness or something yeah
yeah you can only do once well I can
like the Nordic hamstring I can't deal
with that well I can't do a full movie
camera machine code at all but if I
could I'd be able to do it once that day
so that would be the one I'd want to
film
so it just makes things even more
impressive that you're doing that when
you're already uh fatigued well you but
you end up making more gains so by by
forcing myself to film it today then six
months from now it's even easier in a
year from now even easier but
um you know
that that works for me I would recommend
that for Content creators don't start
filming until you did your workout your
program so you actually live your
product yeah and and then think of the
shoot as just part of a long-term
process and if you mess up your line and
now you have to do another handstand or
another stretch or another Nordic Pearl
or whatever
great more games actually that's really
good advice and I think that's that
comes down to leaving your ego at the
door as well because which is yeah I
preach but I should practice a bit more
because I I don't want to um yeah I want
people to see my good handstand on there
and say yeah I always feel like every
video has I like have one move where I
demonstrate I can do at least something
decent you know so I kind of want to get
it in there but yeah you're right if I
have learned recently that actually
lowering the weight when I'm
demonstrating is I do a better
demonstration and you don't have like
I'm not like the top athlete anyways I
don't know why I feel the need to
demonstrate that it's just because you
want some kind of credibility really I
guess you want to you want people to
think he can lift a lot so
well you're demonstrating competence and
as a as a Creator people want to follow
a path that actually works like if it
works it should work so if I'm going to
tell someone to jump higher
I should be able to go up and dunk and
if I mess up my line I should be able to
go do it again and if I mess up again I
should be able to go do it again so it's
just part of the journey and that way
instead of being so stressed about this
video now today you're you're treating
yourself
as part of the journey and now you're
going to get better in the long run it
gets easier and easier yeah now I think
I'm gonna I might I might adopt that
approach myself it's good advice
yeah but yeah it's it's also a funny
thing where you
you want to be advertise your own
product and I don't think necessarily
that every trainer you'd meet in the gym
certainly not to your extent like you
you can be coached by a football coach
who who isn't good at football or you
know is older or but you know for you
you're not only preaching it you're also
demonstrating it to like such a high
standard which I think is part of the
reason you've stood out so much
yeah same same with your channel oh
thanks so you always spot your own your
own mistakes and flaws don't you so it's
yeah yes yeah but it's great because by
us treating ourselves with that kind of
game that we need to be able to
demonstrate these things we need to be a
product of product yeah well then you
get much better at helping other people
if I say well naturally I just have less
flexible hamstrings well then how
effective am I at helping someone no I'm
I want no weak links
no tight links anywhere I want to be
fast I want to jump high I want to I
don't want I don't want there to be
anything that I couldn't help someone
else through and that's more pressure
now and it's harder to face the ego now
but then you get really good at it you
know as a coach you can figure things
out you can figure out a route you can
bring up your weak point so
that's that's really made me is is
having that level of responsibility that
even if I'm not good at something now
I'm not going to run from that I'm going
to figure it out so then I can be a
better Coach yeah that's awesome yeah
and it is it's the setbacks and the
challenges I think you learn the most
from don't you in fact you know starting
out when I was younger was the stuff
that I found really came really easily
that was where I was actually giving
maybe slightly bad advice to people who
didn't find it so you know in particular
I've always had like a good bench press
I've been good at doing you know so I'd
kind of like when I started out I'd
train people with really high volume
like Drop sets and stuff and expect them
to respond the same way I did which they
obviously didn't always and then you
know but it whereas I've had more issues
with like my back in the past and things
and and certain aspects of mobility and
and that's what's taught me much more
that I've been able to then pass on to
other people and it's way more valuable
than the stuff that came easily actually
so yeah right
yeah it is what it is but like I never
could have become an e coach I am if I
hadn't gone through knee surgeries on
one knee and even the fact that
I tore more stuff in the other knee and
now it's after it so like my left knee
had surgical alterations so by the time
I was tearing stuff in my right knee
I was already just like I'm not gonna
have more surgeries so really like I
couldn't have become
as good of a knee coach if I didn't have
this weird like one knee untreated with
torn stuff the other knee super stiff
from the surgeries like whatever that's
that's part of the journey and really
wherever someone's
weakest link is is probably where they
have the most room to improve their
total performance and also to become a
better Coach yeah absolutely yeah you
you'll like such a living proof of that
like that's such a yeah drastic you took
the like the biggest weakness and made
it into like such a strength it's uh
yeah it's very inspiring as well
appreciate that so um like obviously a
question to follow on from that then is
like what are you what are you focusing
on right now out of interest is there
any area where like you see weakness in
yourself that you're working on
obviously
what no obviously yeah yeah if you'd
rather not not say that's cool but um no
no definitely so
um
I believe in something called structural
balance and someone could interpret that
for themselves but the idea is that
you can essentially get stronger
anywhere in your body in relative ratios
yeah so for me
I was so focused on my knees for so long
that my shoulders in general from upper
PEC to shoulder to upper back
relatively is actually weaker than my
legs and my knees yeah and so so I've
been in my own training really trying to
treat myself
as a client who wants that Symmetry and
the way that I go about that is not by
avoiding my knees or my life like the
idea is not to then let go of something
else the idea is to actually keep
getting stronger ankles stronger knees
stronger hamstrings stronger back but
then I'll give my you know push myself
to get my upper PEC my shoulder my upper
back muscles proportionately as strong
so I've been I've been uh the last six
months or so I've been truly treating
myself as a client not not just sticking
with my strong points only
um
so I'm making good consistent progress
but
I'm I'm not balanced yet and based on
the numbers of my legs I do think I'll
be able to do stuff like like a full
full range of motion handstand push-up I
think that will kind of rep I think that
will kind of represent just based on the
numbers that I'm looking at the the
clues I use for the numbers come from
Charles Baldwin I don't know if you've
heard of Charles yeah so he would use
like uh say a front squat and then you
could compare that to uh an incline
bench press yeah and and so he would use
this with Olympic athletes yeah and you
know if you want to be a hurdler or a
high jumper or a javelin thrower then
you can kind of use these Clues to build
the body so for for me and my goals
which is uh for basketball speed jumping
um but I still want to have the
aesthetic and it's still a contact sport
so it's not football but there's no
doubt that if
that if I stay balanced and and my legs
keep getting stronger but my shoulders
get up to par I'll really be even more
explosive on the court and theoretically
theoretically I'll run even faster if
you look at it look at 100 meter
sprinters they're pretty jacked yeah
yeah
crazy Jack so they're still balanced
yeah so I think
I think for me essentially essentially
overhead pressing like strict overhead
pressing my own body weight
and or full range of motion handstand
push-up I think that will represent me
being balanced and I can't do either of
those things right now so for me I like
to have it really measurable so that's
for me that's like that's like a weak
blend yeah keep getting my legs as
strong as possible my hamstrings as
strong as possible ankles as strong as
possible while being able to overhead
press my own body yeah that would be my
best body I've had what about you oh
well actually um handstand push-up is is
one of the things I'm kind of working on
at the moment too like freeze freeze
standing I can do like on a good day I
can do one or two like not full range of
motion but there's no guarantee I'm not
gonna fall over so I didn't want to be
able to like balance it in full range
generation and
um yeah so I'm kind of like working on
lots of things at once that's one of the
like um criticisms I get is that you
know I'm scatter shot and I'm like
working on too many things at once as
opposed to you know Focus you know
Tunnel Vision on one thing
um to me that's that's kind of fun and
like I'm not in a huge rush I always say
that the the traits are more important
than the skills so like I'd love to do a
handstand push-up but more important is
the shoulder strength and the core
stability and the proprioception so yeah
as long as they're improving it almost
doesn't matter if I get to the skill I'd
obviously love get to the skill but
that's kind of like at the moment that's
a taking a back seat and I'm really
working on on planche I can do the um
Advanced tuck planche but I can't get to
a full planche yet and that's something
that I'm I'm really interested in just
because it's
or in particular straight arm strength
is something I'm really interested in is
that something you've looked through at
all straight armed articles being so
tendon Focus that's actually quite um
I'd say maybe quite relevant to what
you're doing yeah I mean I mean
maybe I'll maybe I'll then get
interested in those things
um in terms of the exact measurable for
me it would be pressing my own
body weight strict overhead press but
but I I think it's a really cool
physical demonstration to do the
handstand push-ups
um I I currently do two weeks with
weights and then and then I take a
deload week yeah but my d-load week is
all body weight training so it almost
gives a little more nervous system for
stuff like Nordic hamstring curls and
things that nature
um on your delayed week nice well I
don't I don't ever like to deload so by
every third week just doing body weight
training yeah it kind of it forces a
deload in a way yeah it changes as good
as a break like they say yeah but I'm
with you I I actually think that uh
you know if someone is going for just
the ego of checking off certain
accomplishments
that's also its own game like if someone
just wants to deadlift 600 pounds or
something of that nature
but I still treat myself as an athlete
anything I do in the gym has no bearing
on my happiness it's how it's how good
it feels to go out and do my Sport and
jump and run and cut and those kind of
things so so for me
I pursue 28 different goals all at the
same time I say I say that's quite
similar in that regard yeah so I have 28
different physical like I've added up
all the different things it's actually
28 that wasn't that was literally a 28.
wow right like like I don't want to not
be training the strength of my calf in a
straight-legged and a bent knee position
I don't want to not be training hip
extension and knee flexion I don't so so
for me what's worked best is training 28
different goals at once if I can Whittle
that down to less than 28 I will but for
me right now there's 28 different things
in my body
that I want to be improving and working
on all at the same time
yeah I break it up on average
um
I hit those 28 things over a two-week
period and then I do a week of body
weight training uh so
so 28 things over 10 sessions so I'm
really not working that many things in a
session usually three to four exercises
in a session
um
but but yeah so I don't someone could if
someone criticized you for saying you're
doing too much at once well
if you look at the the richest athletes
in the world yeah it is from having it
is from the well-roundedness of the
capabilities meaning
like Cristiano Ronaldo is not going to
be able to win a gold medal in anything
in the Olympics nothing yet he wouldn't
win high jump but he jumps like a
[ __ ] Kangaroo on a soccer field he
wouldn't win 100 meters but he's fast he
would he wouldn't win anything at the
Olympics and most Olympic athletes are
struggling and have to have sponsors
just to put food on the table yeah he
had a guy making hundreds of millions of
dollars
is a specialist in nothing yeah no
that's true yeah that's a good I always
use arguments like you know for example
most of us aren't ever going to be the
fastest or the strongest but I'd much
rather be like faster than 90 99 of
people and stronger than there to 90 of
people which actually relatively easy to
do because so many people don't train
but you don't actually you don't have to
be like you'd have to be doing crazy
numbers to really be like really
competent so as long as you're at that
level like for most people then you and
I have got like an interest in
particular going a little bit further
than the necessary perhaps but like
particularly for the average Joe who
like can get too too focused I think on
one thing and and and you know obviously
we've both been able to make progress in
multiple areas at once like it might for
me it's been slower than it would be if
I just focused on one thing but you know
recently my planche has improved gotten
slightly better with my uh with my
boxing and things you know all at the
same time improve some Mobility so yeah
and for me that's more fun as well like
it's um it's a passion rather than a job
in that sense
totally yeah so and it's also it's not a
criticism if someone does want to be the
fastest 100 meter Sprinter yeah of
course yeah that makes sense to be the
best arm wrestler but do you think do
you think Conor McGregor would win
anything at the Olympics
pathetic in every single event but if
you add it up he's pretty mobile yeah
exactly and MMA is a really good example
of that that benefits that so that's I
think that's why a lot of people a lot
of people who enter MMA watch my channel
and just because it demands so many
different traits at once you can't yeah
just be good at one thing if you want to
get particularly MMA any martial art
really but MMA because you're doing the
wrestling and the punching need to be
powerful have good endurance even
Mobility any training with either portal
didn't they um which is out there but
yeah but cool exactly exactly so that
that's my take on this for for me in in
sports and in longevity which those are
my two goals so I love the fact that I
can go out and dump for me it's surreal
having grown up not even be able to grab
the rim but it doesn't even seem real
but I want to be able to do that when
I'm 40 45 50 years old
like that's the that's the epitome so I
need the
I need the sports ability and the
longevity and to me for sports and
Longevity the secret weapon is having no
weak or tight links to me that's the
weapon and then it's easy to keep
everything it's easy to run faster you
don't have the setback that you're like
well I would have run faster except I
pulled my hamstring so yeah so for me
that is the
to have no weak or tight links and then
to not let any one quality get ahead of
the other qualities to me that is the
the secret weapon yeah well when I'm
doing like hundreds of push-ups people
say are you going to get repetitive
strain injury enough to me I'm like not
if I'm also doing body weight raise
because like you're canceling it out the
issue isn't like your body doesn't have
a set number of reps but rather any
imbalances that's the issue so exactly
when you were when you're like pursuing
all these different goals do you apply
the same atg system across the board so
like to do handstand push-ups are you
taking the same principles that you use
when you're training in these and
essentially applying it there and is it
is it a very because I I figure that
you're you have a very strong focus on
the tendons in particular um so does
that also apply for the handstand
push-up and how for that with that
example how would you apply that there
yeah I can tell you exactly how to apply
it so
uh you mentioned the balance so if if
pressing overhead is one zone of
pressing
I'm working that once every three weeks
I've also once every three weeks working
with dumbbells pressing overhead to keep
some balance between sides yeah I'm also
once every three weeks working an
inclined bench press for that zone just
kind of underneath the shoulder press
yeah I'm also once every three weeks
working a dip so I'm I'm quite literally
working from and I'm working a neck
press so I'm working a neck press once a
week I train upper body twice a week
yeah so I have I have uh neck press ones
every three weeks I have uh handstand
push-up once every three weeks dumbbell
once every three weeks incline once
every three weeks dip once every three
weeks so
um so I'm just I'm quite literally
training the whole range of pressing and
yeah if we look at the opposite side of
that I'm doing a trap free raise which
is actually like that's it you're on a
45 degree uh back extension and with
straight arms in a v-shape you're having
raise your arms and I'm working on an
incline bench on a Powell race so I'm
here yeah and I'm working on an external
rotation so I'm here and the external
rotation is done once every three weeks
with dumbbell and then once every three
week with a band where there's no
tension here and the tension is there
and I'm doing body weight grows and I'm
doing chin up so I'm also and I'm doing
pullovers so yeah but you have a you
have a net press but I also have a trap
free rate it's getting stronger that way
and a pullover getting more mobile and
stronger that way so it's
that so for me it's not the secret is
that there is no secret yeah and the and
the the best
chance of results and resiliency and
athleticism for me is having literally
no weaker tight links so my so that's my
that's my strategy to a handstand
push-up is that plus literally
everything else in Balance to that see
that's really like really quite
different from like what you'll see from
most calisthenics athletes as their main
um like what they say to do but I also
it makes like perfect sense because in
that scenario if you slightly get out of
alignment you're strong in that position
to catch yourself and and control
yourself and yeah particularly when you
you mentioned the um coming all the way
down to there because most people the
handstand push-up isn't straight up and
straight down as it's kind of like this
motion when you do the full range of
emotions so yeah and what's also so and
what's also like stands out not only are
you attacking every single angle but I
also you also go into a greater range of
motion than your typical
um like uh actually that you that's you
know it's like neck press and things a
lot of people stay away from and I heard
you say I think on
um Mark Bell's channel that when you're
doing your dips you go extremely deep
and things like this which which looks
alarming to people but that's again
where you're where you're training those
tendons and and like those positions
that you can get into and it pays to be
strong in those positions so yeah
essentially the Theory
exactly a short-sighted view is oh that
looks
that's probably what you need to be able
to do like it shouldn't yeah yeah when I
see it it doesn't look like it would
hurt me and I don't have any shoulder
pains or problems yeah but you could
overdo any range so if someone sees so
when I do a dip it means the the
shoulder has to go below the elbow it's
a very simple everything has some kind
of a simple measurable form yeah so the
dip yeah the shoulder goes below the
elbow and if I went to the local gym and
someone didn't recognize me
someone might walk up and say oh watch
out you're going to hurt your shoulder
well
not if I'm doing that at my level once
every three weeks not if you realize
that that regresses by doing a full
range of motion push-up which even
regresses by being on your knees and
doing a full range of motion push-up so
my mother my mother has rings in her
garage and she uses the Rings and walks
out a bit and does full range of motion
push-up with the Rings
so I don't believe there's any such
thing as a bad human motion I believe
you you could someone could Wrangle a
body out of a natural motion but if if
you're doing a natural human motion I
don't believe there's any such thing as
a wrong human motion and I believe in my
only fear is the imbalances and emotions
that I can't do so if someone said with
the shoulder
if someone was was very weak pressing
behind the neck relative to a flat bench
press to me that is what I then see is
the person having shoulder surgeries not
the person who can do it and if you
can't do it will then be addressing that
and fixing why yeah yeah that makes
sense because like why would you be able
to get into a position that that would
hurt you like I mean I always like I
think my wife from ticket is always like
stop talking about us in the wild but
the truth is that in the wild we we
wouldn't know not to get into this
position because it causes impingement
or whatever only pressed this way yeah
so like theoretically the most uh the
healthiest shoulder if you had a twin
brother yeah would be you know if one
only did a flat bench press never worked
the rotator cuff muscles never worked
the opposite with the row never worked
pressing from every angle so it's that
to me that is the secret is that there's
literally no secret and it's you want to
be you want to be balanced
in at every angle the one one of the I
always think that a potential approach
that I've been sort of mulling over
lately is is to like if you if you
instead of like trying to address every
single thing individually if you just
provide yourself with enough of like a
chaotic stimulus so that you so that
you're swinging so you're climbing
obviously it could be dangerous because
you know you need to prepare yourself
for that but like eventually like you
can
I wonder if you can address everything
just almost by osmosis for example like
like from rock climbing because you're
going into every position without
thinking about it or I need to do this
angle and this angle and that angle but
it's happening you know as a byproduct
of what you're doing that's so it's kind
of like a I mean I think um I think
there's a lot of Truth in that because
then when we see like the number one
most shoulder surgery producing activity
is pitching a baseball
yeah you're thinking you're taking a
ball that weighs less than a pound
and that throwing a ball that weighs
less than a pound is the number one
activity you can do if you want to wind
up in a hospital for a shoulder surgery
yeah but you're only throwing
in one way with one arm and then you're
doing it so much more than you would do
like you said in the wild yes yeah if
the pitcher then worked the exact like
the three things I described the Trap 3
race the power raise and the external
rotation those are all the opposite of
throwing so my strength system is
usually just addressing areas that are
commonly imbalanced or tight or weak and
so and then you would have and then you
have two arms so like
if I was trying to take a a young
athlete and make them a professional
pitcher I would try to have them the
strongest of any of their peers in the
exact opposite of throwing and I would
have them do an equal amount of training
with right arm and left arm not even for
the sake of using it in the game but
just to keep the body more balanced
because sometimes you'll see like
quadratus lumborum muscles muscles in
like on either side of the spine yeah
that are so imbalanced and one side is
super flexible and the other side is
super stiff and then you wonder now you
have a picture with mysterious back
problems who can't even pitch so but
but you get back and you get these wild
imbalances in the body like the body was
made to work right it wasn't designed
that we're gonna have to take
painkillers for your back to hunt food
on the table so but if you're a pitcher
in baseball you probably have terrible
imbalances if you're a basketball player
you have probably put so much more
pressures into certain angles in your
knee yeah sure yeah never bending the
knee through a full range of motion so
if you take a basketball player who's
already
putting so much more Force than the
amount of actual strength that's there
for the knee yeah and then in the
training you're saying well because of
the knee we're going to avoid it even
more that's quite literally how you
produce an epidemic of knee surgeries
like if you wanted to produce an
epidemic of surgery for an area of the
body you would overuse the crap out of
it and then avoid fortifying it yeah
there you go yeah which what people did
obviously all these extreme ranges of
motion that you get into you wouldn't
recommend that as far as I'm aware for
someone who's just starting out
um but you you tend to build them up to
that as anyone would and from my
understanding this is where the short
range motion and the long range motion
comes in and is that right and could you
explain a little bit about that
yeah I was thinking about the best way
to describe that so
um we've already established that my
opinion is that
you basically want no weak or tight
links so
it's not about which angle is best to
press from or which angle is best we
want to be strong at all the angles so
if we take the knee as an example the
knee is the biggest joint in the body
and it's got some pretty big tendons on
either side and that does appear to be
the number one like tendonitis is like
tendon pain in the knee sure
so
if you were to move that through a full
range of motion
but if that hurts then we're probably
doing a little bit more
breakdown that you might be able to
realistically recover from so it does
seem like it could work to just force it
yeah but
I think the sweet spot is
quote unquote regressing an exercise to
a level where you don't have any pain
yeah but if you look at something like
the knee you can often take someone who
currently has bad knees and thinks they
couldn't go through a full range of
motion
but then let's say we take a very small
range of motion of the knee over the toe
and then we gradually put in a lot of
reps at that and build that yeah that
would be considered short-range training
Okay so
so short range training is particularly
advantageous to getting a lot of
circulation and a lot of blood flow
like like the toughest thing on a tendon
would be like on a cold day
trying to do a [ __ ] squat out of
nowhere that might be like the toughest
thing unattended but
then something like dragging a sled
backward for 10 minutes straight has
quite literally got thousands of people
on painkillers for the knee but that is
not how you bulletproof your knees it is
it is building to the fullest range the
fullest quote-unquote pressure that you
could take a joint that is actually how
you make it more resilient so it's
understanding that any exercise is on a
scale of range of motion so so if we
look at the knee
and if we think about doing a slide
backward or doing a reverse step up
that's another one that you can scale to
really really easy levels
so compared to just don't let your knee
over your toe first is
finding a short range of motion with the
knee over the toe building up strength
yeah now you start to find that some of
those longer range exercises all of a
sudden don't hurt as much yeah and
there's been multiple uh points of
research done
on reverse step UPS where you're you are
driving the knee over the toe yeah and
these were not done on big high steps
we're talking low steps and it also
appears that a low step with a slant
like with an angle
and you actually can develop and build
tendon yeah so the first no needs over
toasting
came from a finding out that when your
knee goes over your toe there's more
pressure on your knee so it's actually
finding those points of of pressure
which is where we can potentially
stimulate the tendon to grow yeah so
if you can get someone into a
short range of motion but they can
really pump up and get absurd
circulation yeah that's going to carry
over even though it seems like a short
range of motion that's going to carry
over then in your efforts to deeper
range of motion so then if you looked at
um
like what I dreaded as my favorite
exercise the ask to grasp split squat
because you're one knee at a time
because the the imbalance but from one
knee to the other is a huge factor in
knee problems like it's not just a Weak
Knee or a strong knee the amount of
people who have a stronger left or right
knee than the other or different
Mobility is staggering particularly with
people with knee problems so the reverse
step up one side at a time
that's like my classic short range
exercise and I use to show how simple it
is
I use a rubber wedge because a slant
board can definitely work but to put a
slant board on something can be a bit
tricky it can be the slant board can
kind of slide so someone can get someone
can get an industrial sized door stop so
that's what I use to adjust the result
so this is not some fancy invention it's
just bigger it's just a bigger door stop
yeah um so this this elevates the heel
so the ball of the foot is down
by assisting yourself you can get just
about anyone into this because we're
talking about uh less than the amount of
strength needed to go down the stairs so
it's you're turning going down the
stairs and going back up the stairs
backward you're turning that into a
precisely measurable strength exercise
done for a higher number of repetitions
over time that's like your foundational
short range knee exercise now imagine
you have a twin one of them avoids knees
over toes the other one builds up
strength in that short range you now
have more muscle tissue you have more
tendon tissue you're getting more
circulation to heal old injuries
now when you start to progress into a
full range of motion split squat
there's less chance of pain there's more
strength there so those two exercises
alone
finding the level you can do without
pain progressing then to Turning those
into strength exercises those would be
my two classic short range yeah and long
range knee exercises the short range
more for the healing and stability and
building a base like theoretically maybe
you don't need to do short range
training theoretically maybe just do the
full range of motion and you would be
fine however it seems to funnel to it
and it seems to help balance it out and
prevent over training so I gotta do each
one of those one day a week one day I do
the short range one day I do the long
race and if you looked at most people's
leg training you would usually find
that they're usually training just in
mid ranges so most people are used to a
lot of mid ranges and are never like a
normal lunge you're you're in like a
mid-range yeah you're not really working
the short range you're not really
working the long range but someone with
pain on lunges
can do short and long range training
develop the muscles and the tendons
and then they find that now the
mid-range is more potentiated and so
Sports is more of a mid-range activity
um and then there's still another range
though all right
there's still one more range which is
outer range so yeah
so something like a [ __ ] squat that the
most bulletproof of the bulletproof of
these can do that's really getting into
an outer range it's not just a long
range like when you do a full range of
motion squad or split squat you hit a
resting Point like it stops yeah it's a
long range it stops but when you do a
[ __ ] squat it doesn't really stop it
actually it's almost like you're at like
the limit of like stretch that can occur
that's an outer range like for the back
I would consider like
like a Jefferson girl to be like an
outer range exercise whereas a Romanian
deadlift with the stretch in the
hamstring going as deep as you can with
the back strong I would consider that a
long range exercise okay and then
imagine a back extension working and
getting an old person I got my my wife's
mother is in her 70s
walking around with a limp yeah I got
her doing the basics of short range
training walking backward
and doing back extensions with her hands
on it so just working a short range yeah
so that's able to build up strength so a
back extension the top of back stench
will be a short range a Romanian
deadlift would be a long range or a
seeded good morning would be a long
range with bent knees yeah but then a
Jefferson curl would be like outer range
so a Jefferson Pearl a spiffy squat
those are like outer range and I
personally think that for upper level
bulletproofing those become valid
exercises so it's not the purpose of the
outer range to place even more pressure
and strain on the tendons to give them
an even greater stimulus yeah you can't
use the muscle at that point to prevent
it because it's it you know that full
stretch
exactly exactly so so usually without a
range you're thinking much much much
much lighter weights much more
reasonable not something you would do
like 10 sets of a movement or something
like that
um but then in the short so at the short
range level you have very fast recovery
time like imagine imagine if you just
went on a back extension and you just
held that position just to get some
strengthening for someone who is very
very weak and immobile they could
probably do that multiple times a day
the the backwards sled
is shown that you recover within like
three hours like you could theoretically
be doing that multiple times a day but
then something on the far end by the
time you get to the outer range I only
advise that like once every other week
like once every 14 days yeah yeah
because it's quite interesting you're
saying you train these things once every
three weeks in some cases as well and
that's the office enough stimulus to
still progress yeah because each range
because each movement is carrying over
to the other movement so I'm not saying
train your hamstrings once every three
weeks I train my hamstrings twice a week
three three weeks in a row so I train my
hamstrings six times over a three week
period but six different ways yeah that
makes a lot of sense and when you're
doing the short range would you say that
um high volume is a is a particularly
important aspect of it because when
you're doing your backwards walking
you're doing many many more steps
obviously you would you would do a lot
more of that than you would do you know
some a [ __ ] squat which you might do
for it yeah exactly like I do
I do like if I'm if I'm Circuit of
exercise
yeah that's a lot of reps so it's it
doesn't mean that short range can only
be done for High Reps you could do like
the reverse step up I'm talking about
you could do that to a one rep max if
you wanted to yeah but the to me the
advantage the advantage of short range
is being able to pump circulation in
such a safe manner being able to build
base strength in such a safe manner so I
could so on a scale I tend to do higher
reps
more frequently in a short-range
exercise and then less total volume less
frequently in a longer range of exercise
and so for and for the short-range
exercises well is it also working would
you say like almost as a form of
occlusion because you're maintaining the
contraction is that one of the ways that
you're funneling more blood to the to
the tendon
it's it's very possible I keep things
like in layman's terms like I don't
I I don't go
um
someone could take it to much further
scientific depths but the idea of
essentially if you look at a knee
training it through its entire possible
range of training and then just applying
common sense so pump pump that [ __ ] up
in the short range yeah pump it up and
then gradually build resilience for
longer ages and the whole thing always
working at a level without pain and
and now you have a very powerful system
so even though it seems like common
sense because it is common sense oh
what's the secret to knee tendons
is
being capable having ability for the
knee tendon's entire capabilities their
entire so your quad tendon on top and
your patellar tendon on the bottom
having great pain-free capability
through their entire
areas that they could be stimulated
that's very common sense but at the same
time we're having doctors of physical
therapy around the country reaching out
saying how now they're integrating some
of these simple things and their
patients are making much faster recovery
everyone I talk to now is just like oh
yeah I got this from these over toes
it's like yeah it's like an epidemic um
a guy who comes on my channel fairly
regular you might have seen if you've
watched Liam Ellis he's a parkour
athlete he had terrible knee problems
and he credits his recovery entirely to
your system so like that's something I
went to train a gym across the road and
started like talking to this guy and
he's doing your coaching program like
it's just everywhere people are meeting
the gym you see them donated juice right
squats like you know across the pond as
well but it's it's spread and I think it
it is because it's to me the the short
range stuff in particular it really
speaks to me because in my experience I
think there's like a there is a
particular benefit to doing really high
repetition and just getting that blood
flowing and also maintaining the
contraction even because some I say I
always I do these high rep push-ups when
I was a kid I started working out
because I was watching action movies and
I I started doing high high rep push-ups
but they were terrible form push-ups
because I was doing this really short
range of motion but I think as a result
of that and then I went to the gym and
just from like pure this feels good I
was doing like really deep um flies
which again is something that a lot of
people advise against but I've since
learned that Arnie used stuff like that
to go as pecks but I think because I'd
pumped the peck so much and like the
vascularization I've since learned you
know is permanent you get a permanent
greater blood flow at least chronic you
know greater blood flow so it can
recover better it's less likely to tear
so I think I was it by combining those
things I think I was able to like bring
my pecs up much further than the rest of
my body by sheer accident and and since
then I've applied similar principles
like with with bicep curls I do these
like as a test I wanted to see if I
could have a similar effect I just did
like crazy
um mechanical drop sets so and drop sets
but I do you know lots and lots of reps
and I switched to a different angle
switched to a different angle you know
that I could carry on with and although
of the weight and I found that this yeah
it seems like a lot of people frown on
high high repetition and bodybuilding
style training but I actually think if
you combine that because then the
bodybuilders can have full range of
motion if that's all they're doing but I
think if you combine that with with
greater range of motion which is exactly
what you're doing I think that's like a
I think yeah it's like a secret sauce
because you're covering both ends of the
spectrum
um yeah and I think so by doing those
short information exercises it makes
loads of sense then you'd be able to
safely progress to those really
long-range motions and then do things
that appear superhuman but you're able
to do it because you've built yourself
your way up there which um yeah and it's
just awesome
yeah that's right and it's
it's
it almost seems weird and to someone I
could totally understand if they heard
it and they're like that makes no sense
but the secret is that there literally
isn't a secret and it's it's the zone
that you're missing out on it's the zone
that you're not training that could be
you know what's holding things back
um
so like you went and instinctively
worked through this long range of motion
but maybe if a beginner who didn't have
a base tried to just get into that yeah
or what if you had stuck only with the
short range emotion or what if someone
only did a long range of motion so you
you have these only sides that are kind
of missing the point which is not about
like a study doesn't need to determine
which is better short range or long
range like it's going to be you're
probably going to have exponential
benefits by doing both they used to test
this with jumping like what's better
jumping or lifting and they found
actually like an exponential amount of
jump increase by getting stronger and
jumping versus only jumping or only
getting struck but it's like it's and
that's where it's it's hard for me to
even want to be a part of the side of
things that does studies because
if you really take your time and read
hundreds of studies you come to this
conclusion that we didn't even need any
of the studies yeah because it was just
it was just common sense the point is
that when you when you learn so much
about a subject it almost then becomes
insanely simple and it's like whoa so
now it's like when people ask about the
back or something
I instantly know that they have a weak
or tight length or some imbalanced area
or they're doing some activity out of
balance to the rest and we have to
correct those things does that mean
does that mean that now they get to walk
on clouds and float and Escape physics
no they're gonna die just like all the
rest of us and all the rest of us
no matter how bulletproof I get my knees
I can't jump off a six-story house of
land so we have these human limits but
human life has been whittled down quite
deep into thinking
how many surgeries and drugs and just to
get by sorry I don't know these trash
guys going by right now it's super loud
I I can I can send you frustration but
it's you say it's common sense but I
don't know why it's not but it but it it
wasn't like you've yeah I I don't
understand either how it got to that
point because like like you say people
discovered that when you put your knee
past your toes it puts more pressure on
the joint but picking up a dumbbell puts
more pressure on your bicep and does
that mean you shouldn't do it like why
are there specific areas isn't it where
people have been really afraid to and
and the back but like it is obvious but
it it did need someone to say it and I
think that's where your stuff is like in
so breakthrough and then beyond that
like the the specific you keep coming up
with these exercises or just
rediscovering exercises in some cases
that have been overlooked like I'm
definitely going to start integrating
your seated good mornings because I
think
that's the only problem is finding where
that imbalance is because I I clearly
have some number one missing link so in
in training so many people that exercise
is the number one most likely to be to
be the missing link in the back because
we never get that is the closest
actually that the thigh comes in
relationship to the Torso without the
lower back uh losing its its strength so
that's
that is the most likely missing range
but yeah so like I I I think it could do
me a well the good I've done everything
to try and fortify my back it runs in my
family a bit of a a back issue and I I
fixed it for like a year and a half and
it's not the end of the world it's just
a strain but I'm just like why is that
still my weak link you know I did it the
other day and it's it's 90 better now
but I I just it's very frustrating when
you've you've done everything that you
think you can to strengthen it and then
it still happens but it's just another
Avenue to explore I think actually I
need maybe a bit more hip mobility as
well
um
Mobility can help and um if you look at
the if you look at the seated good
morning
this is and you would start with
dumbbells but this is the thigh and the
Torso this is the low this is the
closest they come into contact so
basically every everything you do with
your back
from that exercise everything else
is going to be uh that much more
protected yes it's the um
my favorite for the knee is the atg
split squat in the sense of
The General
stability
that you're not going to have some freak
accident and hurt your knee yeah for the
back
it's the seated good morning yeah so I
think I'm going to be integrating that
on top of all my bridges and my
everything else but yeah I think that's
that's you know you've discovered this
thing that you say is obvious but no one
else was saying it you've also found
like so many great exercises great ways
to train and again when you say them
you're like I saw you do one as well
with a cable machine that's genius like
why aren't more people doing that like
but you know it's a yeah you've
definitely got a gift for this sort of
thing
I appreciate that but yeah it's it's
just trying to address the full range of
motion with common sense of you know how
much and how gently and how to get into
the the whole thing so
um and you know I was kind of saying
how I don't like to go along with the
crowd of like
research and studies but I should give
some
I should give some background on that
really quick yeah so if we think about
um
that it was that it was a study in 1978
that scared everyone away from these
over toes yeah only for it to be found
later
that training the overtow returns
athlete to sport faster builds the
tendon yeah only to only to still find
that even a full range of motion squat
contrary
to popular concern actually makes you
less likely to have a knee injury
strengthens your lower body but now
what's my favorite exercise
one side at a time
full range of motion squat yeah do we
really need to do a study on that if
we've already determined
that being imbalanced increases knee
injury and training a full range of
motion reduces knee injury so no wonder
it's my favorite even though so I get
attacked for being unscientific but I
would argue I'm being the most
scientific yeah I would argue that I
would argue that the atg split squat my
conclusion that that is number one
I would argue that's the most scientific
conclusion that a person could come to
based on the actual research but Men's
Health did an article I cited my sources
yeah and then they pretended that
there's no evidence and they tried to
make it a the title of the article was
um controversial and then they
interviewed people with phds who said oh
we don't know any evidence about this
even though I cited the literal evidence
done by people with phds so they
wouldn't they they want to be
responsible for like an accent Soul
might have if they were to do it too
quickly too soon with too much weight
and that's that's that's why people are
so reluctant to say it but by by
covering their own backs to actually do
people a disservice which um you know
again you've sort of been brave to come
out and say which I shouldn't be brave
to say like you say you put your knees
every days when you go down the stairs
it's not like it's not this isn't crazy
stuff but um like
I can't can't remember the yeah studies
can be infuriating because they'll take
something so out of context like when
they're looking at you know the
difference between like I've seen
studies looking at the difference
between frequency and volume and
training but they're like you know
they'll take the same volume of training
and put it across the frequency that you
know a different frequency and then say
you know it didn't work and it's like
well you can't say that frequency
doesn't work when you you should be
doing more volume or like that's a bad
example but the point is they they they
often it can be useful if it's well
designed and if you then take it in the
context of other things but so often
people they take this really unlikely
scenario they compare two things
precisely and they forget that you know
in the real world you might also be
doing this or they might be trained
athletes or they should have done their
prep you know they should have
strengthened that area
of course and then that's
and then at the end of all that
every study every
and every common sense and it's all it's
all based on much more fundamental
science that doesn't require any studies
just physiology of how things work but
you don't have to have a study to
to feel that when you
do backward slide correctly that you're
pumping up the area yeah yeah so
so
I like to approach it like that and I
like to try to explain things in a way
that doesn't require telling someone you
have to believe this because A study
says you have to believe it because that
approach took the entire field of Peace
totally backward and knee surgeries
skyrocketed when they removed these over
toes so yeah
so
that's the good I think the good news at
the end of it is that when you go to a
real master in results on any subject
they're actually going to help make it
simpler for you and so that's my
conclusion on on on knees and on any
joint is that you want to have ability
for the full range and the longer the
range probably the more time you're
going to need to recover and so on it
doesn't mean you couldn't it doesn't
mean you couldn't do the exercise every
day or try to do it super heavy or
whatever but
it's just a general common sense that
the less range you can pump up more and
you can recover faster than the deeper
the range the more potential resilience
you can gain from it but also the more
precise the form would have like how
precise does the form have to be on a
backwards but yeah you think about the
weight on the sled you could put a
thousand pounds on it it just wouldn't
move yeah if I could put I could put my
mom who's 68 years old and I could give
her bad form on a backward slide and
she'd still be fine but you put a
thousand pounds on an astrograss foot
Squat and Grandma's dead yeah yeah so so
you have so the greater range you go
yeah the greater potential reward but
the more you have to master the form the
more you have to recover and then the
shorter the range the more you can get
pumping and get going yeah it's just
like um it's just like the equivalent of
doing a massive one rep max like a
beginner shouldn't do a squat with twice
the body weight doesn't mean you can't
do it it won't make you stronger but
you've got to build up to it you need
perfect form if you're going to be doing
that kind of stuff and you know yeah
it's just it maybe doesn't look like a
lot of weight but because the range of
motion is so extreme you've got to treat
it you know in that way but I'm afraid
I'm gonna have to um sign off in a
second but I just want to say like thank
you so much for this like um I massively
appreciate it
um it's like a genuine honor to speak to
you I've been watching you for a long
time and yeah really appreciate you
taking the time out to talk to me so you
are the number one most appreciated and
recommended life-changing Channel that I
see because YouTube is so active in the
comments and so people give me a lot of
feedback and um
you know hopefully this could be the
first of many and we can we can help
each other out as like-minded people so
yeah to you on being the number one
channel that that people recommend on my
channel well thank you very much I will
yeah ditto say like literally when I
speak to it yeah you're like a an
epidemic
there you have it I think we have loads
to dig into there thank you so much
again to Ben for being so generous with
this type of knowledge do remember to
check out those links down below if you
want to learn more about Ben and the atg
system by the way thank you so much for
watching
bye for now